siamo tornati sul gioco dove c'è il
coniglio che c'è agli spasmi
ecco appunto perché mi sia proprio
perché c'è la mia faccio qui siamo
tornati ragazzi su the joy of creation e
quel videogioco dove ci stanno gli
animatronics anche chiamati i conigli
con gli spasmi hanno fatto la halloween
edition in occasione di halloween di
questo videogioco bello e adesso noi
andiamo a giocarla perché siamo i
temerari e coraggiosi bene cosa che non
ho capito è perchè hanno fatto un
halloween edition e io la sto giocando
solo adesso
salve basta aver attaccato si può
attaccare il telefono che false pronto
io volevo giocare ai flash royale per
caso attacchi a chiamata che mi dai
fastidio porca di una [ __ ] c'è
proprio uno ha una minima idea di dove
minchia siamo perché non ce l'ho ma
basta parlare che palle siamo ragazzi
tesoro cioè figo di giorno di notte fa
un po cagare cui si stanno continuando a
parlare da ora e mi rompete il cazzo si
sente perché è stato illuminato basta
parlare porta di una montanar se per
caso io devo riascoltarmi future
obiettivo hanno smesso grazia di dio
cosa fire vuol dire che devo fare un
fuoco quindi devo danneggiare i dubbi
questi
ottana bastarda me l'aspettavo mai nella
vita hai parlato un'ora e mezza non
arriva sto deficiente no no no no no no
no no zione cyberlink porca [ __ ]
hanno straparlato ha smesso grazia di
dio mi se o scassato il mouse come ho
fatto a scassare il mouse dal trovare un
martello danneggiare eccolo a no questo
è un tubo piace la posso far me lo sento
danneggia i tubi quali questi tubi come
i dané col martello di danneggio quindi
prima devo trovare il martello number
one ha poi danneggi i tubi poi uso
l'accendino per far esplodere tutto e
poi esco ok semplice se trovassi un
cazzo di martello e che cazzo rivi cos'è
sta roba
oddio e la sala riunioni così eccolo ho
trovato [ __ ] teese messo la faccia
se ti vedo allora posso vedere se stessa
di tubi primo tubo non è esattamente
così perfetto l'altro l'ha fatto col
gomito quindi il martello non serva un
cazzo prova tu no numero 1 danneggiato
perfetto per c'è una videocamera fermi
chi cazzo vedo questo video che niente
non si capisce niente
posso farvi una domanda ragazzi ma io
che ho il martello in questo momento non
posso darli in faccia
forti di uno spacco la mascella ragazzi
devo stare zitto perché devo sentire i
passi se non capisco da dove arriva
[Musica]
ok
porca [ __ ] quanto si brutto fermo è
arrivato il favo idraulico che scassa di
tubi mi chiamo timore la madre fa chi è
da g sai no il rumore che senti in
un'altra stanza in realtà ti sei
sbagliato bene premi sono rientrate mi
fire iniziare tutto daccapo [ __ ] va
quindi ho fatto aspettarmi propri teka p
basta a parlare è che fastidio capito
dove il martello poi diventare l'ho
trovato subito trovato subito perché so
dovente tra i più belli
non c'è più il barcellona per il culo
quindi cambia ma [ __ ] deve
cambiare anche la posizione nel martello
madonna su questo non sta zitto la bacca
sassolino smesso in faccia mi spiegate
ragazzi se cambiano la posizione di
quella minchia di martello io cosa devo
fare per trovarlo cioè impossibile nava
che passione allegri disegni sui muri mi
fa piacere spezzano un po questa
atmosfera horror che esiste in questo
punto vero che sono belli vero che sono
più veloce io accorrerà il contrario che
tu a correre dritto e mi chiamano non
capisco non c'è più il muro a casa s'è
fermato poi mi sono fermato
potevo fare il giro e darli dietro e
ucciderli la madre il cugino mi
ricomparso per caso quanto
da nat rocchi è scemo e scemo e scemo
ancora è più il mio personaggio è scemo
anche lui come fai a correre per un
mettere poi staccarti che la prossima
volta che non mi compare più muoio
apposta così mi compare qua perché vita
non è possibile
la bocca
e andato prof quindi se adesso se adesso
lui è lì a sinistra io vado da tutte le
altre parti che non è sinistra e quindi
dove non dovrebbe dovrei trovare un
cazzo quindi sono libero di fare il
calcio ti voglio bene per te vai vai
spaccatutto porca eva è uno è un tubo
quello porca [ __ ] mi sembrava
animatronics ok vice pat spacca se ma
dove vai veloce
anzi mi impegno al 3 mila per cento
forse forse riesco forse mi chiami ogni
volta che lo sta roba rossa mica go in
mano rega che problemi quindi se ho
capito dove basta fare in teoria non ho
capito marcato l'aria però c'è perché
non corri perché non corre perché non
corre il mio personaggio di festa perché
non corre porca [ __ ] perché non corri
porca eva hai fatto un metro vuoi dirmi
che sei stanco dopo metro
magari non so dove il martello quando
non è lì il problema è questo quindi
devo farmi ammazzare per forza perché
qui ecco dov'era l'altro d'altro tipo di
merda perché non li ho visti subito
tutti qual è il problema memoria non so
il martello li vedo tutti tutti li vedo
ma cosa non c'è dov'era il mezzo testa
di mi dovrei messo su famiglia di
martello dove dove dovrebbe essere
[Musica]
ma se io premo il tasto destro fasto
rumore quindi io l'ho hachiro in vari
posti se premo il tasto destro non
sapevo eccole martello grazie a dio park
tech 1 acqua c'era un tubo mi chiamava
storico la vede quando ciò il martello
non mi ricordo le cose porca eva lo so
io
bye bye bye zio che siamo a tre record
record fissato in teoria adesso lui
dovrebbe essere attirato nell'ufficio
perché il suono è arrivato dall'ufficio
e allora amica perché me lo trovo in
giro 14 dai denti o desio dai cazzo ci
credo
55 dove cazzo è l'ultimo due caccia
all'ultimo ma che ha preso la mia presa
però aggiornati relativi cazzo non mi ha
preso non ci credo corni però
di una [ __ ] di quella [ __ ] non ha
bisogno incastrato non è vero non è vero
non mi taccio dai no dai ragazzi
veramente troika [ __ ] [ __ ] figlio
della [ __ ] lai da quando grasso
stavi li mortacci tua
quindi tutto sto bordello alla fine era
era lì sopra cerali di tipo adesso non
riuscirei mai
eccolo che cazzo sta succedendo ora lo
trovo ovunque tranne dove lo trovavo
prima vabbè tak 1 ragazzi ragazzi ho
trovato l'accendino o lo vinco adesso o
non dico più perché ho trovato anche
l'accendino non so come l'ultimo
tentativo ragazzi e l'ultimo vero
tentativo è questo qua non posso fare
altro passo ci crederò se vinco salto di
gioia e non è il mandato non vincerò mai
e nell'arcade room lo vedo
5 kanal di una eva dove l'ultimo
non puoi fare senza l'ultimo tubo
porcaccia lacca mela generò che non ci
credo mai non ci credo mai nella vita
veloce dove cazzo il mio telefono
ok l'ultimo corridoio sono arrivato alla
fine l'ultimo corridoio sì non c'è però
devi correre testa di cazzo con ritorni
con i cori sì sì sì sto in piana cui non
ci posso credere scazzi incredibile poi
sono morto anch'io come faccio il sole
vino impossibile ho fatto saltare in
aria di prodotto bene ma devo star io io
devo scappata sto facendo doveva dove
vado mamma lo so il finale io non scordo
solfin ai nomi spunta lo stesso
animatronics mi ammazzo stato sono
convinti
tra spesso succede come michael jackson
e call center tel
pensavano il canto di roma se io sono
vivo io che sono un essere umano
figurati l'anima tronic che cazzo deve
essere morto a fare sapere questa di gas
non è servita a niente stop che lo
sapevo io
porcaccia vacca gli end cazzola
bellissimo o il più bel gioco degli anni
la trony che io abbia mai fatto fino
adesso fai incazzare che la metà basta è
però è bello veramente pensò il dato è
l'unico che sono riuscito a finire non
sono riuscito a finire neanche uno
questo è lui il primo che finisco
incredibile aver agazzi spero che il
video vi sia piaciuto concludere
l'episodio 50.000 like solo per aver
vinto però che questo video vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi cosa in più sullo
strumento è un mi piace ai capace di
facebook il carico totale descrizione
stasera i siti statici mi chiamo non
posso vino per ragazzi